Hey, I'm John McCutchan,
a software engineer
working on the Dart
virtual machine.
In this talk, I'm going to
introduce the Dart Observatory,
a powerful tool for
profiling and analyzing
Dart applications.
Finally, I will explain how to
use the CPU Profiler to guide
you while optimizing Dart code.
This talk is aimed at an
intermediate Dart programmer
who wants to make
her programs fly.
Observatory is a powerful tool
for analyzing and profiling
running Dart programs.
It's a new type of
tool which gives you
an always-live, hyperlinked
view into the running
state of your program.
Presently, Observatory
consists of six tools.
The first is a
View and Evaluate.
You can view any
object inside the VM--
an isolate, a library, a class,
or any instance of a class.
You can also
evaluate expressions
in the context of these
objects, including expressions
that modify the object
that you're looking at.
There's Code Coverage, which you
can view alongside the source
directly in Observatory.
The CPU Profiler is
always on, always
sampling the running program,
collecting statistics
about where it's executing.
The Allocation Profile collects
statistics for each class,
allowing you to figure out how
many instances your program
allocates of each one.
Now, we can give you a
stack trace at any time.
And this is a snapshot
of the call stack,
including local stack
variables, which
you can view and manipulate even
after the program has continued
running.
And if you're interested, you
can even visualize the Heap.
Code Coverage is an important
tool in testing your program.
That is, if there are
code paths that are never
executed by your
tests, you don't really
know if those code paths
are correct or not.
Now, Observatory gives you
up-to-date code coverage
on demand.
Code Coverage is displayed next
to your program source lines.
A green box indicates that
the code is executable and has
executed, whereas
a red box indicates
that the code is executable
but hasn't executed.
And this is not a good thing.
If you see a lot of red boxes
after you've run your test
suite, you don't
have the coverage
necessary to really know for
certain that your program is
correct.
Lines without a green or
red box are not executable.
Typically, these are
comments or other white space
inside your program.
Remember, Code Coverage
can be refreshed on demand,
so even in the middle of
running you test suite,
you can go ahead
and just take a peek
and see how much coverage
you've got already.
Observatory's Allocation
Profile gives you
live, up-to-date statistics
about what type of objects
your program is allocating.
The Allocation Profile
displays information
about both old and new space.
And this information is
displayed the same for each.
So we're just going
to focus on new space.
So you can see on the
slide, we have a pie chart
showing how much of the space
is used and how much of it
is free.
And alongside the
pie chart, we have
a table of statistics about
collections that have occurred
in this space-- the total
number of collections that
have occurred since
the program started,
the average time each
collection took--
that's the amount of time
that your program has paused
for when we're doing the GC
pause-- and the cumulative time
that all of the
GCs in this space
has taken out of your
program's execution time.
Now, below the pie chart is a
table showing for each class
how many instances your
program has allocated,
how many are alive in a
moment, and how many of them
have survived the last GC.
Remember, in the
Allocation Profiler,
you can go ahead and
manually trigger GCs,
so you can be
certain that you're
looking at up-to-date
memory usage information.
Reducing the number
of allocations
your program performs can have
a big impact on performance.
Because by allocating
fewer objects,
you're going to incur
shorter and less frequent
GC pauses, which is always good
for your program's performance.
Now let's take a quick look
at an Observatory CPU Profile
capture of a game that
uses the popular 2D physics
library, Box2D.
Dart's Profiler aggregates
samples into buckets
that we call Tags.
And the root of this
tree is the Default Tag
that is set automatically when
your program begins executing.
If we expanded the Default
Tag and we see the VM Tags.
And VM Tags are
categories of execution
that the VM sets while
your program is running.
So sometimes, the VM has to
transition over and compile
some functions that have
never been executed before.
And so you'll see the
Compile Tag show up.
But we can see from
this profile that 95%
of the time, the
Script Tag is set.
And that's good,
because the Script Tab
is set when we're actually
executing Dart code.
Now below Script, we see that
the next highest tag is 3%,
and that's GC New Space.
So right away, we can see
that this program is spending
95% of its time executing, and
only 3% of its time garbage
collecting new space.
And they're spending
little time elsewhere.
Now expanding Script shows us
the hot functions in Box2D.
We see at the top solve velocity
constraints, solve position
constraints, sin, and cos.
The seven functions highlighted
on this slide account
for more than 40% of
all CPU time used.
These are some
pretty hot functions.
But sometimes you're
going to look at a profile
and there won't be
any hot functions.
And we call this a flat profile.
Now in this case, you
can use custom tags
to help aggregate and reveal
where you're spending time.
If we want to see who called
solve velocity constraints,
we can expand it's
node and we can
see that 100% of the time
it's called from island.solve.
And further if we want to see
who called the island.solve,
we can expand its node and we
can see that 100% of the time,
it's called from world.solve.
So we can already see
that Box2D is spending
most of its time solving the
world's velocity and position
constraints.
And if your game is suffering
from a performance problem,
looking at the constraints you
use is the obvious next step.
With only a few
clicks, we've been
able to gain a high-level
understanding of how
the program is
running inside the VM
and what functions are hot.
Now that we've done
a quick overview,
let's take a
slightly deeper look
at the data displayed
by the Profiler.
The Observatory
Profiler is structured
as a tree, rooted with the
categories of execution which
we call tags,
followed by functions.
You can configure how
the tree is displayed,
putting VM Tags before User
Tags, or the other way around.
Or you can hide either set of
tags if you're not interested.
Above the Profile tree, you'll
notice a summary is displayed.
In this case, the
samples were collected
over two minutes and 11
seconds of wall clock time.
We collected 120,000
samples at 1,000 Hertz.
This is also where you configure
how the tags are displayed.
Below the summary, you'll
see the Profiler tree.
Each row in the
tree is either a tag
or a function whose
name is displayed
in the center of the tree.
For each tag or
function, there's
two numbers associated with it.
The first number displayed
to the left of the name
is the percentage of
its parent's node.
And the second number displayed
on the right of the table
is the global
exclusive CPU usage.
Here, we've expanded the
Default Tag and the Script Tag
and you can see that solve
velocity constraints is
8.92% of all script execution
and 8.6% of global CPU usage.
Because the Script Tag is so
close to 100% of the program's
execution time, these two
numbers are really close.
Otherwise, there might
be a larger discrepancy
between the two.
This screen shot
shows the call tree
expanded to show more
of the call chain
to solve velocity constraints.
Note that the exclusive column
for the callers is close to 0%.
Intuitively, this makes
sense because these functions
do very little work
themselves other
than call to other functions
that do the real work
all the way up to solve
velocity constraints, which
is a hot function
in this program.
Optimizing programs is
an art and a science.
The science is understanding
exactly what your Profiler
is measuring, which
we just covered.
The art is making effective
optimizations, which
often requires intuition about
your own program and the system
it is running on.
Let's talk about the cycle
of optimization in general.
The cycle begins with
measuring using your Profiler.
And at first, you're
measuring to identify
the hot spots in your program.
These hot spots
are the functions
that you're spending
a lot of time in,
or the tags that you're
spending a lot of time in.
Once you've identified
the hot spot,
you want to create a
representative benchmark.
This benchmark executes the
hot spot with typical inputs.
Technically, this
step is optional.
But it can really help
with your iteration times
if you have a
canned program that
exercises the slow
path of your program.
Using this representative
benchmark, measure again
with the Profiler.
This is going to
give you a baseline
to measure your
optimizations against.
Without a good
baseline, you can't
tell if the changes you've made
made things better or worse.
So with your baseline,
you're ready to optimize.
This is where your own
intuition comes into play.
Your goal is to minimize
the amount of time
in the hot spots, and there are
many different approaches here.
You can experiment with reducing
the amount of work done,
caching results, or using
different algorithms entirely.
Now that you've made
a change that you
think will speed
your program up,
prove it by measuring again and
comparing with your baseline.
That way, you can
say definitively
that you've made your program
5% faster, 10% faster,
or it's had no effect at all.
You repeat this
cycle until you're
happy with the performance
of your program.
Before I go, I'd like to leave
you with a couple of tips
on optimizing your
Dart programs.
In the Profiler tree,
optimized Dart functions
are prefixed with an asterisk.
If your hot functions
aren't optimized,
you've got a problem.
You're probably triggering
excessive deoptimizations
or prohibiting
optimizations from occurring
in the first place.
You need to understand
why that is,
because optimized
code executes much
faster than unoptimized code.
And so you want to make sure
that your hot functions can
and are staying optimized.
You can get a high-level idea
of how your program is running
simply by looking
at the VM Tags.
And there are certain patterns
that you should come to expect.
For applications which
do lots of computation,
you should see Script
very high up there.
You're probably
allocating too much
if GC is high, in which case
hop over the Allocation Profiler
to help understand
what you're allocating
so you can minimize that.
Applications that do lots
of file and network I/O
should have a hot Native
Tag, because the actual I/O
is done by calling out
to the operating system.
So for server applications, you
want to see a hot Native Tag.
I'm John McCutchan,
and you just learned
about Observatory and
the Dart CPU Profiler.
You can learn more about
Dart and Observatory
by following the
links on this slide.
Thanks for watching.